vous êtes arrivé à maurepas en quelle
année alors 1967 et déjà il y avait une
centaine d'habitants dans cette ville
nouvelle qui était en train de se
construire dès la fin de 67 nous avions
déjà des contacts avec le curé de bord
pas le cher père périlleux et avec lui
nous avons eu des contacts au printemps
1968 pour créer l'association
paroissiale de maurepas avant même de
parler construction nous constituons en
quelque sorte une véritable communauté
paroissiale la communauté paroissiale
elle ne l'a pas de l'inauguration
combien de fêter elle date de quatre ans
auparavant où nous avons eu des réunions
régulières et chaque fois que un
quartier nouveaus habitait nous étions
avec le prêtre toujours soucieux de
réunir dès qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui
s'annonçait comme étant une famille
catholique de faire des réunions chez
elle avec le plus possible de monde je
fuis les deux mois avant la fin de la
guerre de 14 18 j'étais à 14 ans malade
du nahd élite qui pouvait être que mes
recul 2 j'ai eu la chance d'être soigné
par les frères de saint jean de dieu
dans leur centre héliomarin du croisic
sachant que je n'étais pas du tout
croyant une bonne dame m'avait dit si tu
être bien vu n'hésite pas à faire tout
ce que les frères ne demanderont de
faire ce qui fait qu aussitôt qu'il a
été question de la leaf se confesser
j'étais le premier à lever le doigt et
pendant trois semaines
jalel samedi me confesser mais d'une
manière tout à fait hypocrite et un jour
que je revenais de cette confession je
revois legault long couloir chez les
frères de saint jean de dieu j'ai été
obligé de reconnaître
que quelque chose se passait en moi et
j'ai décidé alors là de me confesser
d'une manière réelle à la prochaine fois
c'est à dire le samedi après six mois
après j'ai eu la visite de lieux
jocistes de mon quartier qui m'ont dit
viens donc à l'assemblée générale t
comme noah jeunes travailleurs ça ne
plaisait pas du tout je n'étais pas dans
le coup et puis ils ont ajouté
malicieusement
mais il y aura du cinéma alors je dois
avouer que je suis allé à la réunion
parce que on avait promis le cinéma
enfin qu'il n'y a pas eu cinéma il
faisait très froid et il reste que je
cette réunion là l'amitié les sujets
proposés m'ont absolument
conquis et à partir de là j'étais un
jocistes est un fidèle aux offices
religieux de manière totalement sincère
l'a vu aussi m'a fait découvrir le
christ et m'a emmené jusqu'à ses années
de guerre ou après avoir été mobilisés
j'ai rencontré à la géo c'est une même
dirigeante que moi dirigeante au plan
national
qui était de besançon et nous nous
sommes mariés en juillet 1944 en espère
aller jusqu'aux soixante dixième
anniversaire l'année prochaine pour
faire une belle fête de famille
également quand on s'est rencontrés ça a
été un bonheur dans le christ nous
faisons encore à notre âge tous les
matins la lecture des textes du jour et
une prière au seigneur alassane vierge
ça joseph qui nous réconforte nous avons
eu grâce au seigneur cinq enfants ses
cinq enfants nous ont donné 15 petits
enfants et dix de ses petits enfants
nous ont donné à ce jour
arrière-petits-enfants le dernier étant
né en février de cette année en gt ans
ait mon prêt sa femme et le 78 nous
avons été sollicités par une jeune femme
et qui s'occupait des retraités et qui a
qui nous a dit bc bâle temps à vous
apprendre la comptabilité et puis depuis
bien nous sommes fidèles à tout ce qui
se fait
aussi bien les réunions mensuelles nous
y participons nous les préparons nous
répondrons au mieux à tout ce qui est
demandé mais nous pouvons dire que
véritablement le meuse le mouvement
chrétien des retraités nous aide à vivre
notre vie de retraité et notre vie
religieuse
qu'attendez vous des jeunes aujourd'hui
qu'ils nous disent eux-mêmes ce comment
il envisage le re leur avenir
dans le christ et et vers la paroisse ma
jeunesse a été porté par cette consigne
en quelque sorte de l'agît oc à savoir
fier pur joyeux et conquérant c'était de
quoi motiver les jeunes fougueux que
nous étions si pouvions faire des
bêtises comme tout un chacun mais cette
devise je la conseille aux jeunes qu'ils
soient dans n'importe quel beau
mouvement
pour les aider à
gravir les échelons de l'âge qui viendra
forcément